bei diesen Jahres mitgeteilt dass ich
die Aufgabe des Beauftragten der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz für Fragen
des sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs und des
Kinder- und Jugendschutzes abgebe ich
denke nach zwölf Jahren ein richtiger
Schritt nach dieser langen Zeit und nach
meiner Ankündigung ging dann damit
einher dass die Bischofskonferenz die
Arbeit auf diesem Themenfeld neu
strukturiert und auf breitere Schultern
legen möchte und das haben wir in diesen
Tagen hier auch in Fulda intensiv
beraten und beschlossen
bevor ich Ihnen die Eckpunkte der
Neustrukturierung vorstelle freue ich
mich aber natürlich sehr Ihnen auch
meine Nachfolger und dessen
Stellvertreter Bischof Dr Helmut dieser
von Aachen und Erzbischof Stefan Burger
von Freiburg hier vorstellen zu können
auch wenn jetzt die Aufgabe des
Beauftragten für die Fragen des
sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs nicht eins
zu eins in die Nachfolge übertragen
werden das werde ich dann gleich noch
skizzieren in diesen Eckpunkten aber da
habe ich sagen dass ich wirklich froh
und dankbar bin für die Bereitschaft der
beiden Mitbrüder die Aufgabe anzunehmen
und natürlich dass man da hat dass die
Vollversammlung den beiden ausgesprochen
hat denn damit geht die Aufgabe die
Aufgabe und dieser Bereich in engagierte
und zuverlässige Hände
wie sieht das aus mit der
Neustrukturierung ich habe ja im
vergangenen Jahr bei der
Herbstvollversammlung einen Vorschlag
vorgetragen bzw zunächst mal das
Anliegen vorgetragen diesen Bereich neu
und breiter zu strukturieren und wir
sind dann über verschiedene Stationen
der Beratungen in den letzten Monaten
auch weiter in der Frage einer
Neustrukturierung vorangekommen wir
haben mit den unterschiedlichen Akteuren
die da wichtig sind gesprochen uns
beraten mit das ist natürlich vor allen
Dingen ja auch jetzt durch den Beschluss
zum gemeinsamen Synodalen Weg ein
wichtiger Punkt haben das mit dem ztk
gemacht mit der Deutschen Ordens oberen
Konferenz mit einzelnen Expertinnen und
Experten vor allen Dingen auch aus den
Diözesen die im Bereich Prävention
Intervention Aufarbeitung tätig sind und
natürlich weil wir da auch im stetigen
engen aus sind mit dem betroffenenbeirat
bei der Deutschen Bischofskonferenz und
ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch sehr
herzlich den beiden Vertretern danken
die bei der gestrigen Beratung unserer
Vollversammlung aus unseren Betroffenen
Beirat auch da waren und ihre Expertise
und ihre Perspektive auch eingebracht
haben
die Vollversammlung hat und auch die
Vertreter aus dem Betroffenen Beirat
haben den Eckpunkten die wir jetzt heute
vorliegen zu dem folgenden Konzept
zugestimmt und ich will jetzt Ihnen ein
bisschen skizzieren wie diese
Neustrukturierung aussieht zunächst die
Ziele benennen und dann vor allen Dingen
die einzelnen Elemente die dazu dienen
sollen diese Ziele auch zu erreichen
wir fangen nicht beim Nullpunkt an nach
12 Jahren das ist klar aber und das ist
ein erster Punkt an erstes Ziel es geht
um eine Verstetigung dieses Bereichs das
will ich auch offen noch mal hier sagen
wir haben bisher das Jahr immer in einer
Art Projektstruktur bei der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz
[Musik]
verortet natürlich mit jeweiligen
Verlängerungen aber es ist auch das hat
sich in den letzten Jahren gezeigt es
ist ein Themenbereich die Bekämpfung des
sexuellen Missbrauchs und anderer Formen
von Machtmissbrauch und Gewalt der
stetige Aufmerksamkeit braucht und
insofern braucht es auch diese
Verstetigung Neuordnung und das ist auch
ein wichtiger Punkt Bündelung der
verschiedenen im Laufe der Jahre
ergriffenen Aufgaben und Maßnahmen
Bündelung auch deshalb weiß ich ja
gezeigt hat dass ich das Feld wenn man
es denn bewusst anschaut wenn man eine
größeren Sensibilität dafür hat auch
ausweitet ich nenne nur das Stichwort
geistlichen Missbrauch ja also wir haben
gesehen es geht eben nicht nur um die
Frage von sexualisierter Gewalt sondern
was gibt es auch an anderen Gewaltformen
jetzt gucken wir besonders unseren auf
die Institution katholische Kirche in
unserem Land die zu verhindern und zu
bekämpfen oder aufzudecken aufzuklären
sind und das Feld ist breit sowas
braucht auch da wieder eine in dem Sinne
Bündelung in der Befassung damit es soll
weiterhin auch eine größere
Unabhängigkeit geben jetzt über diese
bisherige Konstruktion Beauftragter der
Bischofskonferenz mit Unterstützung des
Sekretariats hinaus nämlich durch die
Etablierung externer Kompetenz breiterer
Partizipation und auch strukturierter
Einbindung von relevanten Akteuren wie
ztk Ordensoberen Konferenz aber ich
denke besonders auch an das ubs-km Amt
also Frau Klaus mit ihrem Stab auch da
gibt es natürlich jetzt schon in den
vergangenen Jahren sehr häufige Kontakte
aber auch dass hier das ist unser
ausgesprochener Wille die Beauftragte
der Bundesregierung mit ihrem Stab
soweit sie auch da bereit ist und
Möglichkeiten hat einzubinden
es soll mehr Transparenz geben durch
größere Nachvollziehbarkeit von
Prozessen die auch in der Zukunft ja
sozusagen da sein werden also Prozessen
der Weiterentwicklung wie kommen wie
kommen Beratungen zustande wie kommen
Entscheidungen zustande also auch diese
Prozesse nachvollziehbarer zu machen als
bisher und auch Qualitätssicherung zu
etablieren durch einheitliche Verfahren
und eben daraus resultierende
Verbesserungen
die Neustrukturierung sieht für diese
Ziele folgende Elemente vor das erste
und das ist vielleicht das was sozusagen
am stärksten ins Auge fällt als Neuerung
ist die Einrichtung eines unabhängigen
expertenrats dem nebenexternen
Fachleuten verschiedene Disziplinen und
Professionen auch Vertreter des
Betroffenen beiratsangehörigen sollen
und in die Arbeit des expertenrats soll
ja auch Erfahrung Einfließen von unseren
Akteuren die im kirchlichen Feld
unterwegs sind im Bereich Prävention
Intervention und Aufarbeitung ich werde
nachher am Schluss dazu auch noch mal
was sagen denn das ist ja eine große
Zahl von Menschen die jetzt in den
letzten zwölf Jahren in dieses Feld mit
großem Engagement eingestiegen sind